E aí
o tempo é algo que não podemos restituir
por isso grande
é quando era a rádio e fica Paulo eu te
pedido nos corredores
desaparecido chamavam de Zé Paraná
para que tinha o Zé Carioca que era um
pouco
mais duro e os e Paraná o caipira no
Paraná com aquele ever tradicional
mas o meu apelido que também eu pesava
pelos corredores
Ele atende o terror das empregadas
domésticas as minhas fãs no rádio e você
sabe tem um chuva Ney José na painho eu
me chamo José temos que ajudar na Bahia
que tem o meu nome é porque a sua mãe
era uma fã minha
e
como é que eu sei como tempo RJ no Rio
de Janeiro a Jornada Mundial da
Juventude São topada e 17 momento da
sala de imprensa segurança tem alguém
querendo
bem fui eu disse fazer
eu sei que estava brincando mas não é
esse lhe contou a um pouco da história
voltou que a mãe dele gostava muito e
por isso deu o meu nome consigo dela até
ela queria me conhecer até escreveu
inclusive para um programa do tipo de
sangue na época
poder me conhece né e
não faleceu sem me conhecer o seu filho
veio me conhecer e trazer o abraço da
mãe tem um sonho simples
descomplicado distância do tempo dos
quilómetros um que permitiu a realização
dos sonhos tudo bem então a semente Está
Aquele Abraço só eu perguntei como era
ter o nome de Silvânia José
a resposta adoro foi minha mãe de Deus
o
peso sonhos as versões desejar
intensamente
esperar pensar em coisas ambiciosa sou
difícil
DH
dos nossos sonhos
Convido você agora pense em uma pessoa
que você respeita o livro quem sabe o
que que você gosta né que representa
para você um exemplo de força sucesso
talvez
Pelo ela eu já famoso não menos famoso
mas que para você importante não é
como ela um daqueles heróis ao lado eu
acho que traz edigas aparentemente
enorme
uma importa qual foi a estampa a sua
realização ele fez especificamente só
uma coisa em pó
aquela pessoa que você tanto respeita
provavelmente não teria feito
coisa se tivesse comigo e as pessoas
quem sabe o que os outros disseram
negativamente sem ouvir o próprio
coração
ao que a gente tem tempo para o uso
muitas empresas que não deixamos o
sonho só podem ser realizados antes Se
você tiver a coragem e muitas vezes
contra opinião com muitos riscos é por
isso que muitos lingus eu mais sonho
e o erro imperdoável para aqueles que
querem encontrar
e seguir as coordenadas da sua
felicidade Júnior
e a juventude
e muitas pessoas ao nosso redor que
compartilho uma característica muito
precisa
a gente tem amigos assim
vamos seguir são muito realistas
ou na realidade não pense
que julgam os outros
projetos os seus dizendo claramente que
sempre coloca uma racionalidade em
primeiro lugar mas depois que que
acontece não são nada razões
juramento e
do lado oposto
um dos sonhadores
são aqueles que nem sequer ouvir seu voo
para mudar sua vida
porque o Marco como enviar para mim
possível Já pensou nisso começou isso é
impossível
Eles me dizem para crescer colocar a
cabeça sobre os outros isso é realista
porque isso é o que a vida sofrimento
acredito que você não é destinado a
Viver Como dizer não
E isso não é isso é assim mesmo vida
e não tem que ser uma guerra
as pessoas ao seu redor quer você goste
ou não a minha com o banco você vai
aprender a música e se você beber você
perde sempre se lembrar de fazer uma
seleção na entrada da sua vida e termina
muitas partidas
e perdeu os sonhos bons sonhos porque
ninguém podia ter
eu nunca pensei eu pensei que
queria ser médico mas minha mãe queria
um filho muito junto com 16 anos não
queria muito longe de casa
a vida me deu sonhos canções mas
aproveitei o que ela me deu mas quando
comecei a sonhar água fervente Conheço
não esse desejos eu comecei sonharam
eu deixei o Brasil para ficar somente
seis meses aqui militar passaram
esse período voltei a estudar já tinha
feito duas faculdades que estamos
estruturados e me deparei com alunos
dentro de uma sala de 20 nacionalidades
vida
surpresas
para você vai pedir uma vez eu tava
tentando explicar o que significa água o
sentido de narração a narrativa os
alunos ele que tava muita gente
conversando eu subir em cima da carteira
e falei agora vocês vão olhar para mim o
que eu vou olhar de cima para baixo
esse momento entre o redutor de canda
faculdade
a droga estava alterado estava falando
alto e entrou e saiu depois acontecendo
o que que aconteceu que você tava
fazendo
para dizer às pessoas que viviam olhar
no osso das pessoas e não para o saco
Isso é uma questão de características e
não dizer sempre assim
eu
gostaria de dizer vocês não sonha
comigo
e se considerar muitas vezes o
julgamento daquelas pessoas
que vem tudo negativo
liga o chip abandona o seu medo de
parecer iludido cima de tudo
muito maior que o medo de falha o
fracasso não é um problema encontrar o
significa que você tentou eu tenho que
significa viver sem arrependimento uma
coisa aqui no finalzinho da vida dentro
da atrás não gostaria de ter momentos de
arrependimento parte não Pode admitir de
pastel
um
sonho grande fazer mais nada porque você
pode tipo de pelo se a sua mente 30
futuro que você vive em outra cidade ou
país outras pessoas no outro emprego
Volta profissão e pode completamente
impedido
planejar uma grande mudança de vida
e
ninguém somente você
e a grande força do sonho Zé Ninguém
pode temos é como tentar parar o rio
como com as mãos
a importância de sonhar grande
show
no limite
você já tive o conservador seja usado
mais longe se puder
quem
sabe
para falar de sonhos eu vou morango Lu o
Brasil e trabalhava em rádio de um
programa é do fundo e dentro deste
programa radiofônico eu tinha momento
que se chamava Coisas da Vida você já
pessoas que me escreveram Contando um
pouco da sua vida
um belo dia apareceu tava na minha sala
uma senhora mas se por lá a secretária
diz olha só bonita uma senhora aqui quer
falar com você pois não
havia entrado toda de funk para mim é o
problema no leitor ou todo medicamento
alta então
e coloca uma fotografia em cima da minha
disso essa minha filha
ele tem 16 anos e está grávida
o
senhor em que posso ajudar ele chorar
parava de chorar ele contou a história
dizendo que a filha estava noite saída
da escola ocupada
ela ficou grávida
Bom dia já tentado se matar duas filhas
eu não queria
sentir
humilhada e a mãe ela dizia não vamos
tentar resolver
e ela veio conversar comigo rádio pessoa
que eu não conhecia que ela não me
conheceu não ser através duro E aí ela
falou eu sou católica eu não quero que
ela possa a menina isso a cantar
qual era o grande problema de tudo isso
é que eu posso lhe ajudar o pai dessa
menina estava internada no Hospital
pró-cardíaco não sabia disso
a Yamaha disse eu não posso contar para
o meu marido porque senão ele vai embora
e qual era a solução encontrar a família
a eficácia menina Durante os próximos é
seis meses
começo 6 meses e depois a criança seria
mas eu iria sobre a briga dos o meu pai
queria sabemos ela contaria uma história
para o pai e filha estavam é o grande
emprego em Curitiba negócio Grande
e no dia seguinte programa radiofônico
com telhas história
o de uma mãe que sonhava uma vida
diferente para sua filha o sonho de uma
mãe a gente sabe como abaixar um banho
Shopping
sonho grande para você
o e naquele momento ela não tivesse
pesada
contei a história e pedir se alguém
quisesse ajudar essa família que
mandaste simplesmente ligasse para rádio
sobre o telefone e depois eu daria sem
telefone para essa senhora ligar ele ia
saber quem não sabe é uma coisa muito
privada muito difícil
e que acontece
mais disso 50 amigas ligaram oferecendo
sua casa para receber essa menina e quem
sabe depois de um
O que acontece no dia seguinte
essa senhora eu chego a raiva sete da
manhã encontro ela mora com a filha
filha veio correndo
cheirar joelho e pegou na minha mão e
sempre
nesse momento
pesadelo virou
uma grandíssima realidade o que acontece
ela chegou ao hospital para conversar
com o pai nem falei como é que está e
esse pai disse pode ouvir o programa do
Silvio Ney hoje estou com meu coração
ele contou uma história de humano de uma
menina que tá passando por dificuldade
nós temos uma filha eu fiquei tão tocado
que nós que nós podemos ajudar ele não
sei o que que você acha e a mãe começou
a chorar copiosamente
é esse pai do velho e perguntou
secamente
nossa filha
a escolher
ela veio me contar o pai disse com os
olhos cheios de água antigos ele iria
criar até primos
é uma chamada depois eu vim embora
aproveitar eu não sei o quê Pois o que
aconteceu com tudo isso para vocês
porque tudo que a gente pensa na vida
e pode mudar
nós temos que estar lá
nós temos que viver a nossa vida dos
Imigrantes
é só que não há portanto
vive a sonhar grande porque um sonho o
primeiro passo para a sua felicidade
o fato de um sonho ser algo abstrato não
significa que ele não tem repercussões
concretas também e sonhar a primeira
peça e seu Efeito
Dominó Porque os sonhos
último ligar o motor do carro
coloque movimento começa acreditamos Ok
já que você não acredita
é
uma piadinha para vocês
depois disso se atrasarem para o
encontro com o diretor do manicômio e
atos de novo os
malucos jogo justificam
acordei tarde no Senhor diretor
Sonhei que fui ao Polo Norte e demorou
muito a viagem pela boca muito maluco
imediatamente então na conversa para se
justificar é
esperar no aeroporto e e e
os sonhos sonhados
Sony grande
lua é um sonho
espero que vocês possam motivar vocês
têm cada um no seu coração
que horas é